Kylie Jenner tweaks her tattoo that was  once dedicated to her former flame I  don't feel any different  [Music]  it's been months since Kylie Jenner and  Tyga officially called it quits and now  it seems Kyle Isel has made the split  even more permanent the 19 year old  reality star stepped out on Monday in  London with her new boyfriend Travis  Scott opting for a white top skintight  leather jeans and matching sneakers but  all eyes were on Kylie's left ankle  showing off some altered ink if you take  a closer look her old cursive T tat for  Tyga now reads la sighting comes after  Kylie seemingly cemented her new  relationship with Travis debuting a  matching butterfly tattoo with the  25-year old rapper on snapchat in June  [Music]